you know his son got shot in the face
that's difficult making a movies is a
luxury it's a gift and that may ruin the
next hour of your life my choices my
moment-to-moment choices are choosing
more of a positive perspective rise and
shine it's an espresso time good morning
believe nation its Evan my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have an amazing gift inside you that
I want to see exploded onto the world so
let's start your day off right together
grab your coffee and sip on today's
message put things in perspective over
to you Denzel Washington how's it
garbage man like Troy huh you get eight
hours worth of work but you can do it in
three so you can go home as soon as you
finish post office you get three hours
worth of work and you make it last eight
I did both I like being the garbage man
better but they weren't bad jobs it's
like a people's hole the difficulty of
making a movie I'm like send your son in
Iraq that's difficult it's just a movie
it's like relax I don't play that
precious nonsense oh whoa get out of
here you know your son got shot in the
face that's difficult making a movie
this is a luxury it's a gift it's an
opportunity and most importantly it's a
gift obviously everybody here is
talented enough to do that but don't get
it twisted it's just a movie it ain't
that big a deal trade your expectations
for appreciation if you want to be happy
if you want to have energy if you want
to stay positive then one of the best
things you can do is trade your
expectations for appreciation if you
think about when you're negative when
you're upset when you're really
frustrated it's usually because what you
expected to happen didn't happen you had
these expectations or how long something
would take or how somebody would react
they didn't do it that didn't happen
what you thought in your head was gonna
happen didn't and so you get frustrated
where if you can flip it and ask
yourself when you're in these frustrated
moments
how can I trade my expectations for
appreciation that's when you start to
get the positive energy coming back so a
couple examples if you look at waiting
for an elevator this is one that would
trigger me I'm waiting for an elevator
it's not coming one of the elevators is
being used for moving or it's broken and
you're used to an elevator coming in
whatever 20 seconds and if you're there
for 40 seconds you're angry you're
sitting there you're carrying these
groceries you want that elevator to come
what happened right you had an
expectation of a coming in 20 seconds
but it actually takes 40 and so you're
upset and that may ruin the next hour of
your life through this elevator it took
so long to get here switch it so you go
from trading your expectations for
appreciation so I'll sit there and say
how can I be grateful for this how can I
find some appreciation here one that
I'll think of for the elevator is
there's this magical box that'll take me
from parking level 1 to the 13th floor I
don't have to carry these groceries up
14 flights of stairs I'm really grateful
and all I have to do is wait
40 seconds for this magical box to come
and pick me up we get so triggered and
so upset if a website takes ten seconds
to load and we're upset we're blowing up
we're freaking out right we're just
imagine wow we have this thing called
the Internet we have these amazing
phones and that's not to say listen we
don't want to try to make the world
better right if you see a problem you
see an opportunity you want to go and
make that better for yourself and for
the people around you
but if you're coming from a place of
just insane frustration and being upset
all the time that's not going to help
you get to where you need to go and so
to solve it in the moment treating your
expectations for appreciation there's a
good example that Vanessa van Edwards
came up with where she was driving to
work every day and she always hit this
red life and she got so upset that she
always had this red light for whatever
reason she always hit the red and it
bothered her and she just was instantly
triggered she knew it was coming and so
it hit the red light again I hit it
again and I'm upset she traded her
expectations for appreciation and said
you know what when I hit that red light
every time I hit that red light I'm
gonna sit and think about three things
that I'm grateful for I'm gonna use that
as my gratitude practice every morning I
hit the red light I think of three
things I'm grateful for and so it
shifted now the
light became an opportunity for her to
reflect and be grateful and be happy and
have some positive energy and then I got
to the point where if she didn't hit the
red light should be upset because she
didn't have the chance to sit there and
be grateful right and so you could turn
one of these things that are really
negative in your life and make it
positive just by trying to find ways to
appreciate it and be grateful so I
encourage you to think about in your
life what are the things that frustrate
you that get you really upset that seem
trivial that seems stupid but still just
trigger you and get you into a negative
state and how can you trade that
expectation for some appreciation now
I've got a special bonus clip for you
before getting to it my question of the
day for you is I'm curious what is that
one little thing that triggers you what
is that expectation and how can you turn
it into appreciation leave it down in
the comments below I'm really curious to
see what you have to say thank you guys
so much for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot of espresso and enjoy the bonus
they're part of what this work does is
that when we start to shift our
perceptions when we start to see things
with a better perspective when we start
to see our experiences as as obstacles
turning into opportunities or a
resentment as a divine assignment to
forgive more or a moment of lack as an
opportunity to focus on what we're
grateful for rather than focus on what
we don't have we start to make these
shifts within our life what begins to
happen is that we begin to have more
faith in that way of being and so the
neat thing that occurs and this has been
my experience the past six years of
practicing the life of a spirit junkie
is that now my choices my
moment-to-moment choices are choosing
more of a positive perspective when
there's traffic my first thought is okay
I welcome the traffic to go I try to
start to think about the ways or if I'm
supposed to be late maybe I'm meant to
be there late
maybe there's something greater coming
or if something doesn't happen the exact
way that I believe it should happen I
know and my first thought is there's
something way greater coming so this is
just the type the types of miracles that
occur in the ways that your mind begins
to shift when you start to practice
these principles in your every corner of
your life make wishes
I'm enterpreneur it's very great but not
all days are great in a company so what
are your tips and tricks for your tough
days
I think there's massive confusion around
entrepreneurship entrepreneurship sucks
I mean it's lonely it's high-risk I mean
I can't live without it but it's like a
bad boyfriend right a girlfriend right
like like it's there's a ton of bad days
being an entrepreneur not to mention 98%
of entrepreneurial ventures are gonna
fail so there's gonna be a really bad
day in your future you know hopefully
not for you um for any of you you know
for me I don't you know I think this is
a very personal question I think it's
how you're wired I'm so all-in
entrepreneur I prefer the pain I think
one of the reasons I love the Jets so
much is because they bring me so much
pain you know I I love the climb to me
the setback is exciting I love when
something goes wrong it's where I shine
the most
but that's not for everybody right I
mean it can be very difficult and when
you start affecting your life and your
loved ones and all the other things it
can get real nasty to me the way I
handle things even though the few rare
days when I really struggle I take a
real step back and make pretend that
somebody called me and told me that my
mother or daughter were killed and I
know that's very dark and I apologize
but it's really what I do I literally am
able to at my deepest most struggling
moment within business take a step back
and remind myself that I could make a
trillion dollars tomorrow on Bitcoin and
and if something bad happened to the
people I love the most that it would
mean nothing and it very consistently
rewires me very quickly
I just put business in perspective at
the end of the day you know it's it's
money for me it's not really money it's
my legacy so I get hurt by it a little
bit more but uh yeah I mean it's you
know I put it in perspective it's money
and you know what up until I had a
daughter even while I was married up
until when I had Misha four years ago I
secretly wanted to lose all my money I
had this weird twisted dark fantasy of
losing everything just to rise again
like a phoenix and remind you there's
thirteen years ago you were completely
bust gone no money you had five pounds
and seven dollars left in your hand you
use it for a taxi back to your parents
and your career in the record business
had just come to a sudden shuddering
halt and here you are thirteen years
later you're worth hundreds of millions
of dollars life's taken a huge turn up
as but I get the sense with you there
what happened to you thirteen years ago
still defines you now yeah I mean it
wasn't the best of times but and then
again and when I look back on it it
wasn't the worst of times you know
Biggers III think particularly here in
in Hollywood where where most people get
it wrong is they're afraid of losing
what they've got they're just terrified
of losing their fame as you said power
money but actually once you've lost it
you can always get it back again then
when it's not the end of the world
I mean being ills worse so because I've
actually faced one of most people's
worst fears and recovered from it it's
not as bad as you think you know I
didn't lose my confidence my friends
were still my friends
I've lived with my parents and I just
saw it as a challenge that I've got to
get myself back on my feet again what
advice to parents give you them they
were really you know honest to god they
were just cool about it you know they
were parents they just you know wants to
look after me live with them for a while
my dad left me some money to pay the
bank than eventually managed to pay my
dad back you know it was what any parent
would do but like I said it's it wasn't
it wasn't the worst time of my life and
actually when I look back on it now I
still smile because and I bought this
beat-up old British sports car worked 18
hours a day and I'm so determined peers
just to get it right this time because I
knew why I got it wrong so now I find it
much easier to deal with things if that
wasn't the worst time in your life what
was when my dad died was the worst time
in my life as you know you and I
discussed that it was just that you know
like getting ill losing a parent or
losing a you know somebody close to you
that's the worst thing that could ever
happen in your life you know all the
things that I worry about now she's
trivial I mean you know even the whole
kind of idle expected thing I laugh
about it because it's such a high-class
problem my show is better than your show
is like we're both we both gotta show
Colin Firth and Hugh Grant and the
fountain in Bridget Jones is that quite
exact over what I've made the fact that
we're here we can do this it's a
fantastic raise your standard Apple at
the core is core value
not one drop of myself work depends on
your acceptance of me I don't ever give
up I'd have to be dead or completely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
most a success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link in
description for details